you need to find a spouse who you say  this is how i want to live my life is  that the kind of life you want to live  and so i think a lot of people do this  kind of like trying to meet in the  middle thing and then both people are  unhappy you want to be the most  unreasonable about all the things that  you want to do turn as many people away  as humanly possible and so i think one  of the things that i love the most about  layla is that she has never tried to  change me like a lot of us make these  concessions because we believe we should  or we have to or it's a part of marriage  i don't believe that and i think that if  you want to live an exceptional life  then that means that you will live as an  exception and if you want to live an  uncommon life you cannot have common  views